so what were the key factors in making
your money back the key factors were
having a solid game plan for post
production going into the filmmaking
process I knew that a certain amount of
the budget had to be spent on
advertising and PR so in foreign sales
what you'll find is that you'll be able
to secure theatrical release if you're
willing to put in money for marketing
and so that was a big distinguishing
factor between US and other films where
other films you make the film and you
okay well here's my film can somebody
please buy it whereas you know you want
to you want to finish a film but then
still have a game plan to get the film
out there so with awkward decision we
actually put up the marketing money half
of the marketing money for India and the
the distributors put up the other half
so we we kind of we had a marriage bill
of funds and therefore we secured the
Optical distribution and the awkward
decision was released big in India we
had billboards I mean it was like a film
you would you would see here in
Hollywood like Ocean's eleven where you
see billboards everywhere it was exactly
like that in Bombay which is the big
film hub Delhi as well as in North India
and as well as in Rajasthan I I went out
there I went to different cities visited
promoted to film myself with the
director of the film and so we had a
very solid post strategy on how to get
the film out and we targeted the
audience that we felt would respond the
best to an action drama that takes place
on two continents so people who are more
who want to catch a glimpse of LA as
well as see a story unfold in the Indian
background so we we chose our target
audience very well and then had a game
plan to capture that audience so that
was really the key is is not just
knowing that you finished the film it's
what we were going to do after it was
finished that's that's critical so for
everybody out there you know you know I
know it's all about making the film and
that's wonderful
but the whole idea of making the film is
for people to watch it and the way
people are gonna watch it is if you know
you have PR and you have a marketing
team that is gonna help you so whatever
funding you're coming up with to to make
your film make sure a certain amount of
that is allocated for the back end
you